newsom
is saying he is considering a statewide
curfew daily cover 19 cases have doubled
in california over the last 10 days
forcing the governor's office to pull an
emergency break newsome said
at a press conference detailing the
state's response a total of 41 out of
california's 58 counties
are now classified as purple the tier of
kovitt 19 related spread
requiring the strictest lockdown
guidelines just 13 counties were
classified purple last week
newsom said his team is reviewing
studies from france germany and saudi
arabia
on the efficacy of their strategies as
it relates to curfews the governor
referred statewide curfews of interest
in massachusetts and virginia as
examples of what california
could resemble california officials are
still in discussions on whether to
implement the curfew
and key details about how it could be
enforced since you are from california
how excited are you about this i
can't wait bring it on i mean every day
when that guy speaks i just feel
energized and motivated and i want to
buy a gun
that's usually the en end result of
listening to him
it's coming it's each day they're
thinking of new ways and i'm just
wondering what's the end game what are
they trying to accomplish
by stripping away this you said you go
to the gym every day we haven't had gyms
open since
april march i mean they've been closed
all summer you just get used to it now
the fact that you can't go
into a restaurant bars aren't open gyms
aren't open
basketball nets aren't up because you
don't want people playing basketball
right now
you could die of coving you know it's a
proven fact you play a game on one on
one you're dying
it's over um newsom you know and he's
such
he is such a hypocrite it's just
unbelievable and he's even pissing
people off that like
him you know the fact that he had that
dinner in napa valley for 12 people
a 50th birthday party that he's had to
apologize the sacramento bee
ripped him you know really they they
gave him a a
a a very harsh editorial um
it's coming and garcetti's talking about
even more restrictions for la county
it's next week ask me because there will
be so many more limitations orange
county
who looks at themselves as kind of you
know a maverick almost they like to do
their own thing
they just got hammered yesterday they
have to shut everything down
churches you name it i mean it's just
it's so bad
and they do it in a way that it almost
is normalizing
how you think of things you get used to
it like we have two kids
that are very active in sports you're
used to hauling them around constantly
right pat you're always taking your kids
to practice
to a game you got to coordinate your
schedules it's been seven months without
doing it and
it would feel weird doing it again so i
think
this is all part of a scheme to just
slowly they're using coven i'm not
saying it's not a disease and people
aren't dying of it
and people aren't suffering from it but
it is a politicized weapon
and california is at the forefront of
how they're using it
steve i agree with you 100 percent
although i am a mask wearer uh i'm
social distancing this is other than
flying on an airplane a couple of times
since this all started this is as close
as i've been to most people
my wife and i because of our
semi-retirement status now if we go out
to eat
it's usually mid-afternoon when there's
nobody else in the restaurants
and as i mentioned before we started the
podcast today
when this all first started i thought it
was a politically motivated
approach by the democratic party to be
quite honest with you
until my son my oldest son is an
orthopedic surgeon in atlanta
and i would talk to him about it and he
sent me a letter
that a colleague of his had written a
guy he went to med school with out of
tulsa oklahoma they they
graduated western university med school
uh
and i read this guy's on the front lines
now my son is a is a pediatric
orthopedic surgeon he specializes in
pediatric spinal surgery so he's not
directly on the front line when he's not
doing surgeries he's supporting those
that are on the front lines
when i read what his colleague his buddy
was going through on a daily basis
and the the just watching people die
and not being able to do anything about
it changed my
opinion completely so i believe that
this is an
issue is it as big as the media has
blown it up to be
that i'm not sure but it does not hurt
me to wear a mask
people say i have a right not to wear a
mask i don't remember reading that in
the constitution
you know a mask is not about doing what
this party or that party or the
government tells you to do
i'm wearing a mask is respect that i'm
going to respect your space
i would appreciate if you wear a mask
you know they've done studies you see
the
the uh nih and cdc come out with studies
and you look at the percentages if both
of us are wearing a mask the
possibility if this is true the
possibility of us
passing the the virus to each other is
drastically drastically reduced
so out of respect for everybody else in
the world i'm going to wear a mask you
don't want a mirror mask i don't care
that's your decision you know i think
you can use the data however you want i
think people on the other side can say
that there is no benefit
cdc and i'm not arguing with you or
telling you you're wrong
but you know you have to wear one in
california you when you're out you have
to wear one so
you you have to do it but man i don't
think
you know being indoors i don't know if
you need a mask uh
if you have some symptoms or if you've
tested positive or
i don't know i i don't i think it's odd
when people wear young healthy people
wear masks
inside what's really odd is you see
somebody in the car by themselves
wearing a mask are people jogging and
they're wearing them
we're looking for that can't be healthy
breathing in those fibers yeah i posted
something on twitter
uh five months ago i don't know if you
remember that guy
and it created a rocket six months ago i
saw a guy literally wearing a mascot i
took a picture of it
and i said wearing a mask in a car
driving by yourself
is like wearing a condom in bed while
you're by yourself
what do you have a condom there's nobody
around you then you have a condom on and
you're going
maybe some people do that i don't know
you know you go through the news
the one word you see more than anything
is safe
everything has got to be safe are we
safe this
could you imagine when lewis and clark
were trying to
you know move their way west and
settlers and
it's just constantly having the word
safe in front of you is anti-american
i i think they are desensitizing
americans with the only thing that
matters is we have to save every life
you know we have to make sure
everybody's safe a hundred percent of
the time there's no way you should be in
jeopardy
of contracting this virus so we're gonna
do everything we have to
to make sure that you're safe it's
wearing me out they're going to
legislate our safety
that's so that's what's uh and they'll
have the media on the front lines but
here's the thing i mean if you don't
mind sharing you
you said when you go back home tonight
when you fly back what did you say
you're going to do when you go back i'll
self-isolate for 10 days
self-isolate in the basement for 10 days
so steve's not just saying this and you
would probably consider yourself a
conservative
very very construed and he's still
pro-mask and he's going to self-i say
self-isolate for 10 days do you stay
away from your wife because she wasn't
on this trip then
or your grandkids yes yes just you for
ten days well
like at dinner if so we don't go out and
eat when i'm in
self-isolation and this is only this
will be the third time it's happened
since this whole thing started
so i don't travel too much now but uh if
we order in
then i'll sit in the dining room and my
wife will sit in the kitchen so we can
talk to each other
you know it's it's just we're in the
high risk group because of our ages you
know depending on who you listen to
and it's just not worth the risk i fully
agree with you on that part about high
uh high risk group ages one yesterday i
spoke to dr stephen gundry
who uh uh uh very he has done 10 000
heart surgeries in his life okay he's a
legend when it comes down to that world
and i talked about math because he made
a video about masks
and he made one video saying masks don't
work he says there's no way in the world
that he says as a doctor i wear a mask
for other reasons but for you
you can wear a mask and i still can get
coronavirus through you
and then you know i started asking
questions of what what's your position i
says now i believe people should be
wearing masks said your position changed
he says yes it did if i was wrong i said
it i'm wrong so
he is now about wearing masks but what
found she said yesterday i don't know if
you guys caught what
she said yesterday found she said
yesterday kai did you hear what five she
said yesterday
found she said we may need to wear a
mask forever
in america moving forward meaning this
mask thing
may be a permanent thing in america
think about that forever
we will be wearing masks i think it's an
incredibly harmful thing for him to say
the way the data changes what we just
yesterday the news
was about a new vaccine that has a 95
effectiveness rate so what are you
talking about
more fear more scaring people how the
hell do you know that you don't even
know what's going to happen
in two weeks regarding coronavirus you i
mean and then they're
trying to tell you i mean the cdc
literally has rules out you can find it
about what you should be doing over the
holidays and not singing and doing all
this
outside of what the states are telling
you your local governor the cdc is as
well but
man that that was a dangerous statement
for him to say and why
bum people out to that level why can't
we have hope that the
vaccine is going to work that'd be like
a mis uh
like an uninformed opinion about mumps
you know mumps are going to be here
forever
measles are going to be deadly for the
rest of time
you know and not giving our medical
communities a chance to rough without
flirting with people though i mean just
think about it for the flirting
community
so everybody said like hey let's just
say someone's got pretty eyes
and like how you doing and then all of a
sudden the mask comes down you're like
dude i totally screwed up what do we do
now you go on a date
you know do you make out with a mask on
like how it's like so first base used to
be what first base is is first base
holding what's first space kissing it's
first space
if first base is kissing but that's
without a mask so what is it halfway
it's like with a mask if we get
i'm halfway there to first base is
kissing but this thing's getting very
technical for me i mean if i was single
today be very complicated
thank god i'm married because i don't
have to worry about that stuff but the
single world
man you go on a date hi so what's your
name you know can i see what you look
like then the grill is all
jacked up and i don't know i i just i'm
very concerned for the single community
you know what there's a big tinder's
taking a big kid by the way just so you
know that tinder has taken a massive hit
today
for our tinder community out there clear
mass that's probably the way so you can
actually see what somebody looks like
those freak me out though have you seen
the clear mask they're weird
have you seen the clear mask what do you
think about it when you see a clear mask
actually what do you think about i'm
curious what do you guys think about it
when you see
people with a clear mind you've never
seen it that you have seen it i've seen
it you're going there they're wearing
these masks goes like up to here
oh and it's glass masks yeah what do you
think about that
oh no i saw on the dallas dfw last night
when i landed
to me it's like a little bit uh uh it's
like neiman marcus ish you know because
you know when you wear one of those
ghetto masks i feel like you go to
walmart
when you wear one with like some cloth
and maybe you're going to macy's but
when i see this glass type of stuff like
a shield you're like listen
maybe it's you know apple mask apple
should come out by the way apple could
probably monetize this they come out
with a mask and there's a screen you're
watching tv
and you have the mask on it's next they
would probably do something like that
yeah well they have masks now that you
wear around your ears but this part is
clear
i saw one at dfw last night when i
landed here yeah that's the ones i was
talking about they're freaky i don't
like it
it was it was i don't know why but it
was
it is what it is i just again it's a
very very weird time when it comes onto
these masks and fouchy said
by the way if you're watching this i
know many of you guys are die-hard fauci
fans
fauci said wear a mask forever
how many of you are very comfortable
knowing you're gonna have to wear a mask
for the rest of your life can i say this
can i vote now you are you really not
no no i don't wanna wear a mask the rest
of my life that's what found you saying
though you know i think fauci's a clown
i really do i think he's lost all
credibility every other week he says
something stupid
he back pedals he's a whiner you know he
can't take it when trump says something
about him
i would like the head epidemiologist or
whatever his title is for 35 years
to be a little stronger can we recommend
fauci read that book
no more mr nice guy i mean he really
needs it the guy's a wuss
he really is she no more mr nice guy
that's classic